JUAN SEBASTIAN OVIEDO: Hello.
My name is Juan
Sebastian Oviedo.
And I am a product manager
for continuous integration,
continuous delivery
on Google Cloud.
Today, we'll be talking about an
exciting new feature, Container
Registry Vulnerability Scanning.
Scanning your images for
known vulnerabilities
is an important step in
securing your CI/CD pipeline.
Vulnerability scanning helps
you identify and address
vulnerabilities in images stored
in Google Container Registry.
In turn, this enables you to
prioritize patching your images
to other [INAUDIBLE]
vulnerabilities,
determine whether your
environment is affected
by a newly discovered
vulnerability,
and ensure that your
images are up to date
and protected against
the latest threats.
First, enable the
container and analysis
API to use the
vulnerability scanner.
Once enabled, it
will automatically
scan the container
images you have
stored in container registry.
It uses data from
vulnerability databases
for the supported distributions.
After an image is
scanned, you can
see the list of vulnerabilities
found and their severity
via the Cloud console,
the command line
interface, and vulnerability
scanner's APIs.
Also, the vulnerability status
of previously scanned images
is automatically updated
when new vulnerabilities
are reported to the
source databases.
To learn more about a
specific vulnerability
in an image, click on it
to go to the detailed view.
Using this information,
you can find and get
a patch version of the
effected container image.
If no vulnerabilities
are found for an image,
it will have a green check with
none found in the vulnerability
column.
You can apply
additional security
to your CI/CD process
with binary authorization.
Set up policies to ensure that
only container images that
meet your acceptance criteria
can be used in deployments.
So to recap,
vulnerability scanner
helps you secure
your CI/CD process
by continuously
identifying vulnerabilities
in your container images.
You can use this
information to decide
what images need to be patched.
To learn more, check
out documentation
for Container Registry
Vulnerability Scanning.
Thanks for watching.
[LOGO MUSIC PLAYING]